et on va prendre maintenant la direction
des états unis confrontés à la
propagation du variant delta responsable
selon les autorités sanitaires de 83%
des nouvelles infections ont fait le
point tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas boni
[Musique]
thomas un bonjour bonsoir quelle est la
situation dans le pays et comment en le
gouvernement compte il y faire face et
bien aux etats-unis le variant delta est
responsable d'une hausse du nombre de
cas positifs de 55 % en l'espace d'une
semaine avec un nombre de 37 mille
nouveaux cas par jour en moyenne en ce
moment sur l'ensemble du territoire
américain
et il y a des inquiétudes en particulier
dans les états où la couverture
vaccinale est nettement inférieure à
celle de la moyenne nationale il ya une
question maintenant qui anime les débats
ici doit-on imposer de nouveau le masque
en intérieur y compris pour les
personnes non vaccinées les autorités
sanitaires la cie dc avait indiqué le 13
mai dernier que le port du masque
n'était plus nécessaire pour les
américains vacciner à l'intérieur mais
face à cette dégradation des indicateurs
sanitaires la question est de nouveau
sur la table alors il n'y a pas de
décision pour le moment c'est ce qu'ils
ont annoncé hier et la question a donc
été posée à la porte parole de la maison
blanche est ce que le gouvernement
compte d'une façon ou d'une autre et
imposer de nouvelles restrictions et
puis quelle est la position de la maison
blanche sur le port du masque en
intérieur écoutez sa réponse
il vient c'est actuellement notre
message les communautés parmi lesquels
il y a des cheveux de vaccination plus
faibles et comme nous le savons
excusez-moi concentrer seulement dans un
atelier d'état à travers les pays et non
d'où viennent la plupart des cas comme
nous l'avons constaté avec la
propagation du variant des ateliers plus
transmissible
si l'on n'est pas avec sonné il se
transmet plus rapidement d'une personne
à l'autre cela n est ce que quelqu'un de
jeune les gens devraient porter des
masques et c'est quelque chose que nous
continue afin d'encourager de la part
des leaders les leaders de la société
civile sauf les enseignants et les
personnes dont la parole jouit de la
confiance de leurs communautés à faire
comprendre voilà étant donné qu'il n'y a
pas de directives claires de la part du
gouvernement c'est donc aux états voire
aux comptes et que revient la décision
d'imposer ou non de nouvelles
restrictions il ya par exemple le comté
de los angeles qui impose de nouveaux le
port du masque en intérieur mais cette
décision fait polémique puisque certains
s'y opposent notamment des élus
républicains parce qu'ils estiment que
c'est en grande partie parce qu'il a la
possibilité de ne plus porter le masque
qu'il ya une forme d'incitation
américains à se faire vacciner il ya
aussi la question du masque à l'école
alors que la rentrée scolaire va
évidemment arriver à le mois d'août
prochain voire au mois de septembre
c'est hors de question pour le
gouverneur de floride ron de santis il
ne veut absolument pas que les élèves de
l'état de floride porte le masque en
classe il à imposer des lois à l'échelle
de l'état pour justement s'opposer à
toute imposition de l'obligation du port
du masque à l'école alors si le masque
fait débat aux états unis que dire du
vaccin c'est encore pire puisque des
états ont passé des lois pour empêcher
toute mise en place d'un passeport
vaccinale à des échelles locale que ce
soit dans des entreprises ou des
universités alors il ya quand même des
entités qui impose le vaccin c'est le
cas par exemple à new york où le maire a
annoncé que tout le personnel soignant
de la ville dvas devra présenter une
preuve de vaccination ou à défaut un
test pcr
chaque semaine il ya aussi donc des
entreprises et des universités qui avons
demandé à ce que leurs employés ou leurs
étudiants soient vaccinés évidemment
cela provoque énormément de débats même
des procédures judiciaires qui sont
intentés soit par des employés soit par
des étudiants qui s'opposent à cette
forme d'obligations alors sur ces
polémiques le gouvernement là encore ne
se prononce pas véritablement joe biden
ne souhaite pas à vouloir imposer
d'obligations et d'ailleurs la porte
parole de la maison blanche a été
interrogé à ce sujet il ya quelques
instants elle dit que ce n'est pas le
rôle du gouvernement fédéral d'imposer
une obligation de vaccination et avoue
coup avoue ratoma bonnet en direct
depuis washington